welcome to this video this is some about
the bow masters final again we are
looking at round nine here of ten rounds
total so it's a close to the end and the
game i'm going to show you his cousin
against world champion vishy anand the
situation of the tournament is some that
carlton and dum kawana are both leading
and yeah it's um it's pretty it's a
pretty much a decision between the two
unknown however has played eight draws
up to now and some of them have been
uneventful some of them have been yeah
more more interesting but still he
didn't win a game yet um didn't lost the
game but it didn't look too inspiring to
be honest so let's see what happens him
um with two games left carlton has got a
white against anand and two black
against their own unit if you want so
when the tournament outright he needs to
win one of the games and frankly
speaking white against anand seems like
a better chance than like against
uronian so let's see what card is doing
in this game he's going for a form and
almond um actually goes for the sicilian
here his main defenses against 1.e4 on
the night off the sicilian night off 1e5
and he also plays her the caro-kann um
sometimes so the night of ism basically
the sharpest option but Carlton doesn't
go for it it just plays Bishop b5 check
according to his usual game plan of just
getting a playable position and then try
to outplay the opponent it's working
like magic very often simply because
he's playing
so yeah so strongly after that all right
this would be five check and also I not
recently had problems again this move he
had faced it in the german bundesliga i
right before the World Championship
match in April and they played against
them yeah Russian Dutch Grand Masters TV
our coffee plate 97 which is some
usually am the movie are going to play
if you want to have him more interesting
game trying to get the bishop pair when
white exchanges later but he lost the
game against him Yakov and live in a
very drastic fashion so really rare that
you see a world champion losing I'm such
a game so in this game played just
bishop you said which is a tried and
tested mainline it's difficult to win
with black this with this move it
usually leads to pretty young stale
positions but it's solid so let's see
what happens Queen d7 and now I'm cousin
goes for see form and in general White
has two basic ways of playing them this
position here in this position he can go
for a see 3d for approach trying to get
down get this perfect porn center or I
can play as Magnus did in the game the
c-4 idea with default later trying to
set up this typical Murat see bind um
probably see for its own is more
promising but it's not not clear c3 or
castles is the normal way to go for the
other line it's also interesting so see
form I'm not no Knight f6 if you look at
this position for the first time and
don't don't know the theoretical
background you might ask what is this
move
oops double attacking f ing to and why
them indeed needs to sacrifice poor now
i'm just showing this quickly because i
always thought it's a fun idea quincy
form castles queen e for and deform and
now white will win even further tempos
and will have a tremendous compensation
so queen g4 is probably a far too risky
yeah i'm not played Knight f6 Knight to
c3 covering the for porn ng6 young i'm
like it can also go for an e6 set up
here with Bishop e7 and so on but g
successor you have the the main line and
in general considered fine for black
deformed takes takes and Bishop g7 yeah
now we have this mentioned Murat see
bind very often in this zone type of
pawn structure the bishops the White
squared bishops are still on the board
so why it's bishop is on e to very often
it likes still back on c 8 and this i
exchanged now um at first you might
think that this would automatically
favor wide because this Bishop is
potentially a bad bishop with the white
pawns being on a white squares on c44
and later white usually plays b3 and f3
so it's got everything on white squares
so um the bishop exchange and might
favor him you might think it's not so
clear actually this is a potentially bad
bishop it's not bad outright on e2 and
it's also a fact that black usually
welcomes some exchanges in this
structure to get more room for his
pieces so the bishop 1c8 very often just
stands on descendants doing nothing the
whole game and sometimes you you you
would like to exchange it so I'm every
now this is an important move you might
think it doesn't matter some
which kind of yeah move on a white
choose wide words what is going for but
in fact them if you look at this you
need to play a three at some point
probably because okay you can go in a
completely different direction with age
three but let's say you want to play
Bishop e3 at some point then you must
play a free to prevent night reform and
the question should you do f3 now I
should you just castle first in fact for
years castles love them the main move
but then it was found out that after
castles f3 rook c8 be three black has
some the really amazing move d 5 this
was introduced by Yvonne shook and about
ten years ago and this really changed
this the sole evaluation of the move
orders really have a cool move d5 ok
let's check this cookie just just gives
away a piece so the critical goopher
must be e takes d5 and then black even
even captures on d5 very funny 95 nov
six and black will get a piece back with
a fine position and white has nothing he
can actually yeah he must must save
himself basically here with the pretty
move Bishop to h6 and the Sun very often
is to a quick draw okay it's a slight
digression here but I like this I always
like this idea so this is also the
explanation by cars here on roof nine
played f3 you simply am play the pawn
moves first to prevent this specific
variation and now unemployed Quincy
seven if black wood castle then you
would go here and after rook c8 be three
then d 5 is not possible anymore because
the bishop on e3 is protecting your
night so there's nothing hanging on the
D file and this would be a normal kind
of Murat see bind position with black
playing this move or a six whatever it's
perfectly all right in the game
unemployed Quincy seven which is very
rare move i only found one game in my
database it's not super up to date but
still it must be around move probably
some maybe someone played it a couple
weeks ago or anything but it's a rare
IDM okay Quincy seven just taking this
pawn be three years some a normal move
far though for white and Queen a five
yeah this was the idea a quick
repositioning of the Queen and not so
sure if this is a great idea it cannot
be too bad but not sure if it is helping
much causal just protected the night and
I don't know when 496 yeah just normal
moves castles and castle so yeah and now
what needs to be cautious a bit because
this night is some yeah under fire from
this bishop and of course by c6 so there
are some typical technical tricks in
this position that you need to pay
attention to if you play the really
automatic looking move Queen d2 for
example then black gum place the
standard trick and winds up on ya end
the game basically it's a not just a
porn it's a central pawn now the idea
being that this is very bad for white
and this you can just exchange on d 2
and then grab the form with the
mentioned extra extra central pawn and
like is pretty much winning on this kind
of level Queen d2 is just just typical
blunder that didn't pay attention to the
pressure on deform yeah and also black
gum has this kind of ideas initiating a
pin so Carlton played prophylactic movie
late night c2e2 protecting the d4 light
so that there are no direct them
technical possibilities now on a
playgroup the eighth note that for once
I have the correct times and this
tournament displayed 90 minutes for 40
moves with no increment in the force
first 40 moves so if you look at wishes
clock he only plan to spend two minutes
up to now so this old stuff with Quincy
seven Queen er5 was was prepared he
invested six-minute dawn roop d8 and
yeah this is an interesting question if
this was um part of the preparation
still on yeah or if he was now on his
own and came up with the following idea
at the board it's not not clear rook da
de is a pretty mysterious move at first
because what is this rook doing just
watching over the spawn and it has our
technical IDM which we will see later in
the game another slower idea would be to
play e65 with the Rukia on Gavin he had
a very concrete idea in mind um which
I'm not sure about really its own that's
very difficult to assess what what's
happening next black softly I also could
play play on in the standard fashion
like rook c8 a 6b five try to prepare
this at least probably won't manage but
you can try um yeah rook yet is very
quick we'd we would see what happens
cause the first played bishops III
improving this Bishop position a bit
queen bee six now and yeah with a very
direct threat this pin allows this idea
so you need your step Mick sidestep here
King edge one yeah now comes the
dimensioned idea that Alan prepared with
root dat plate d 5 yeah I think this
idea is quite they are not not so the
edits it's a bit similar to to the the
idea above Yvonne shocked that I that I
showed in the other line and I think
maybe because this other line exists
this idea came came into vicious mind or
maybe it was really am prepared idea but
it's really am related to related kind
of motif this d5 yeah what's the IDM if
white would capture now with the porn um
with it doesn't really matter which one
let's say here then 95s coming and here
it's simply a deadly pin white cannot
avoid to to lose the piece back there is
no way to keep it Queen you won some the
relatively best move but then add some
something like this would happen white
gets the point back only seven but at
the end Black has some control on the D
file and it's somewhat better slightly
better what has some chances thought 02
to hold this of course but it's a it's a
pretty disappointing result of this some
of the some opening so after d5 taking
doesn't really promise much
so contemplate 96 ok black needs to
recapture with the pawn you have no kind
no tricks if you're going for you if you
go for this you simply um have no tricks
IAM because the queen is saying so need
to play a beat xe6 and now cards are
played queen bee one with a very simple
but yeah but important threaten black
cannot ignore this we should be five is
threatening now it's red now to to win
the exchange and down yeah he is maybe
the first critical position of this game
what should black play to our to attend
to this threat I'm not really sure um
the game I don't played look to c 8 the
alternative that i looked at is a 5
which at first I mean this looks more
natural to me but it's um it's difficult
to say this of course and wants to
introduce the possibility of playing a
form and but the main point is that
white will continue e5 which will also
happen in the game it's it's it's quite
similar here and now e6 and this is the
whole light the whole problem or the
whole issue of this position for black
white will will play this and it's a
matter on young of comparison what is
better to have the rukon d8 still and
the pawn on e5 or have this position
with the rook on CA this is the game
position um not sure um I mean at least
I think after e6 black can always go for
d4 here and you shouldn't be too too bad
let's say the deform check here King
takes you should be too and then maybe
five I don't think
this should be so terrible for like we
what can go here but you have half night
c5 it's um I know maybe white slightly
better but it's nothing nothing
spectacular at all this this kind of
idea looks looks nice but black has as
showing you ways to challenge this night
and it's not clear this Bishop looks
potentially bad with those pawns but so
this is a pass porn deform and it's not
so clear how to make any em series
progresses white I mean this was
certainly an alternative to go for go
for this like you can also add set up
default course consider to take it's um
it's not them it's not terrible this
kind of stuff oops the king of course
not f form this can be considered in 95
95 check for example this is not in
really exhaustive analysis but just to
show some sample line I mean this
doesn't seem to be a to be completely
terrible for blanket it's not it's not
very attractive to play yeah you'll be
passive but it's upon its and not
completely clear white obviously has
enough compensation no question but it's
not clear why this really better here
can oops of course here to h6 try out
this kind of stuff but it's not it's not
clear that this is really an advantage
on still in comparison i like this this
other line more with default the Sun
here to play play deform a5 FIA five was
certainly am a good
alternative if they look see 8e 598 yeah
of course here also 97 was what's
something to consider but this is now I
think simply better for white after
ecigs if he takes here now you can
simply retake this is some difference
and in the positions because now you
protect you 6 and what should like do
now probably this move but this kind of
position is simply better for white like
structure here and the King position is
a bit problematic and white has this
some f5 IDM I think 97's is worse really
and what watch what else I'm should like
do everyone who doesn't really have an
alternative here after after the six cm
this kind of oops of course not this
kind of oops here take here um really
gains in strength now with the rook here
instead of d 8 um gap don't know what
black should play here if you go here
then white has this little this nice
trick because this pretty much this is
terrible so after taking here wide also
has this idea and probably you need to
go into this kind of position but why
this is just clearly better here so 97
is probably worse 98 is better and now
statistics yeah what should like do I
think it's very hard to to not take a
six you don't really want to to allow a
pawn to be established there I mean you
can think about what I'm talking about
move like f5 just ignoring the spawn
but looking at this and white some
probably still better here not F for
many are maybe here and see 594 coming
yeah yeah white should be better f5 is
also weird move it's very normal to just
take it you need to get rid of this this
invading in waiting a pcr only six all
right neither for this was the idea get
to get the pressure going on on e6 and
yeah are not just took on c3 Quincy
three and deform Queen d2 guess this is
the most natural square c5 protecting
the spawn and rook you want so what what
to say about this position yeah what a
sacrifice upon but then of course the c6
phone is very weak and also this night
doesn't really make a great impression
white certainly has some enough
compensation for other porn probably as
he has got even a bit more than
compensation but it's um it's not the
last year position or clearly worse for
black yet I think the real problem comes
a bit later here are not like nitrogen
seven protecting the pond at some hard
to suggest them any other move yeah now
strong move by cards and I'm not
difficult still strong g-form you need
to prevent 95 @ f 52 f5 and probably III
must be stopped so g4s good yeah and now
maybe in this position on island made
the first real mistake of the game you
played rook to c6 covering e-cigs from
the side but this fails to address one
that white has in this position and cars
and yes all saw the problem immediately
I guess not sure how much time is spent
but I think like I needed to play Queen
D 60m just to address the idea the idea
is Knight to h3 it's really a bit of
counterintuitive move because you move
the night back from from the center
influence but the idea is simply Queen
to h6 95 ended so it's over on h7 this
threat is in the position end somehow
rooks e6 what what wish you played
doesn't address this threat here in this
position after night h3 you can play e5
and after Queen h6 it's not the best
move probably all this but the idea is
that now you have night to e6 and if
white would play 95 you can simply
exchange with them with a fine position
why do we need five here but it's no big
deal probably am black as some black is
fine Queen f6 is that the point look at
this this should be perfectly all right
for black can play a five a four and
then it's it's simply drawn probably so
Queen d6 I think he had to play somebody
to address this threat of lead to h3 in
the game look what happened how do you
defend this poll now it's really
difficult he needed to really make some
moves here you don't really want to make
and there's not a lot much else really
click 98 now the idea being to play
Knight f6 covering h7 I think this is
the only roof which which at least
continues the game other things probably
at worse um funny idea s
you can also look I d5 by the way again
with the same idea of course in this
position there's no Queen on the 60 e
five I can after this this I can simply
take and yeah white white has a very
good position here is evening
threatening rookie 6 and 9 35
immediately so if flag would make some
some some 0 move here then this is an
immediate win it's probably even am a
frost checkmate yeah it's a false
checkmate Queen h7 h8 on f7 so if I've
home I mean look silly if I've but it's
a move you need to look at simply
because yeah nothing moves just loose to
Queen h6 and 95 I'm funny ideas so King
here Queen h6 Queen to d8 night g5 and
Quinn g8 this is the passive way of
defending um but still I think it
wouldn't help them at the end white can
play f4 and bring a look into the attack
anthem let's look at the sample line
yeah now this is you thread night to e8
intending Knight f6 probably and here y
term can even take on 87 and this winter
immediately this is the easy line with
the mate and yeah like cannot take on 87
but what should you do probably here and
then this is very strong move Queen h3
the idea being okay threaten now to win
with her discover check and if black
takes it there's this
move and why does threatening rook h3
catching both pieces cm the Queen and
the king on the edge file and also this
rook in the corner is hanging with rue
gates result after Queen g2 in fact why
does completely winning yeah it's very
difficult to find the defense after all
after after this rook c6 move and then
983 so yeah what what did on play plate
98 queen to h6 with Knight f6 and 95 so
we have this typical setup while white
is running mate and this night is the
only piece to to avoid the direct
checkmate the problem is that white and
now simply intends to to increase the
pressure only six and if you wince this
pawn it will be M be really terrible and
night only six would help to support
Queen g7 mate and in general losing this
porn on e6 means that in seven is so
weak you probably lose both um yeah it's
very difficult here probably the
relatively best defense would be
something like this Queen a 6-5 and
Quincy eight covering you six of this
fishnet probably having this idea in
mind what did some if you look at this
just for example um yeah this is Sam
just just really bad for black I think
the Roxy six groups of six was really a
really a really big mistake white will
have a very strong position here for the
porn so I'm very difficult to defend for
black if possible at all in the game
Arnold late d3 i'm very surprised that
he said 40 minutes left and didn't
invest more
probably he was a already am yeah a bit
annoyed at himself that he allowed this
this kind of stuff yeah d 3 um it was
answered by rookie 5 and this is again
simple but but very strong move the idea
is to sacrifice on h7 if Blackwood now
try to let's say support the porn with
rock d 8 then white can already
breakthrough with 9 h 7 Knight takes
Queen takes 26 yeah King age 8 this is
very simple just a mate and after this
you can simply take it d 2 and then
maybe in West one move to stop the porn
and next why does what is winning simply
um maybe them giving a check first yet
service is more accurate not sure this
kind of things on and and maybe then
this move not quite sure but right the
widest certainly running here so this
was the threat anthem what should like
do I don't play dumb King edge a to to
defend against this of course you're
directly allowing this kind of check
also it's not doing much at the moment
but it means you cannot put anything on
the default for example ok just rip the
one attacking the pawn and yeah it's
really sad now what what what's blacks
move now if you would protect the pawn
or let's say it looks like you protect
the porn why can simply take it and
cause a very embarrassing moment as you
cannot take because of me cause of this
made um yeah
very sad line that group DHS fails of
course this is also a possibility of the
route III is just is even stronger um
yeah and what what should black do and
unplayed the Queen to a six and yeah now
calculate a fall just protecting the
poem by advancing and in this position
of Ananth resigned yeah it looks them at
first you might think okay is this a bit
early but then it's simply a rack of her
position it's terrible rook d8 it's
again answered by this move so this
means you will lose this pawn and the
position after this is simply is simply
terrible let's say Quincy 8th route d3
Queen here to defend and then just this
end yeah he six is falling you will lose
e six and probably seven and c5 is also
week I mean it's it's just dropping like
em fruits from a tree all those cell
phones that white will win and all in
all this is just a depressing position
just terrible it's so this dark squares
are so dominating my white so we are
really terrible loss here for the world
champion is black and he really is some
is out of form now for for quite a while
I'm not quite sure why it's not my job
to to to speculate with them and it's
not really playing on its level is some
obviously capable of playing much better
than this kind of gamer suggests the a
gap of course am very clean and and
convincing display by cousin who just
took an advantage from all the hoff the
mistake here I think Roxy six really
really is it's clear that this is a
mistake as Queen d6 sm it's a better
defense but this
so position I'm still is quite ugly I
mean I to be honest I don't like this
whole concept here to allow this this
kind of position but this is also maybe
a bit of yeah a bit of an a taste thing
I don't like to have wrecked
confirmations and and a week Kingdom the
secret porn is really really not much
not much fun for black and this is also
why I don't like this this whole idea
that that was played here so much I mean
there's some idea with them this quick
d5 idea which pretty much sure leads by
force to to this some to this kind of
position time I don't like it much but
it's it's really hard to determine
without hours of analysis and if the the
mistake was um before this Quincy of
this not this rook c6 move which is
clearly bad but and queen d 6 is tougher
but it's a question if you maybe if you
look at this form for a longer time then
you may be find out that this is also a
bed for black there are other ideas I
mean I looked at this in the analysis
but white also has other ideas here
which are simply not so yeah so
straightforward but not necessarily bad
from stuff like 93 rupee 5 or rookie for
I mean white has all kinds of ideas to
to put pressure on like what Black is
just defending for just a pawn and he's
got this ugly night on g7 nights on g7
are really a really bad pieces but it's
very rare that the fianchetto and I just
say good piece num ya okay so um a great
win by by carlson who
is some young leading the tournament now
still shared with Caruana who won
against who did you beat I think vallejo
yeah we won against the Spanish player
so before the last round it's um no it
was not well I hope did he played did
you play kayaking another culture by the
karana one as well and in the last round
yeah the problem is they're there
they're shared first and Carson's got
black against aronian and whatever
whatever kiwanis opponent is it's it's
harder then it's easier than playing
aronian with black witches about the
worst you can get ya one maybe one
little tiny bit of extra motivation for
cars could be that if he would win
tomorrow I think it's tomorrow if he
would win against Aronian in this final
round with black he would beat the
all-time yellow record of tomorrow's
passing this 2851 mark i'm not sure if
you really cast because it's simply
given that you will break this anyway at
some point but it would really happen if
he would win this game alright thanks
for watching I hope you like them the
video and probably I do something on the
last round as well so yeah probably an
you'll hear from me again now for for
the final router tomorrow